we told Brent literally like eight
months ago I'd say almost a year ago we
told Brent to record himself having sex
with his wife you know consensually we
asked you know if you date the two of
them erupt for it they were brain can't
figure out how to do it every tape he
gets us you can't like you can't even
hear anything
he keeps saying it's not good enough no
he's actually was supposed to say he's
been working on radio his whole life as
JD's going through the latest tape and
you can barely hear anything yeah what's
going on with you were recording how
hard it's a little more difficult than
you imagine why you take home a big mic
no I haven't taken home I'm trying to do
it on my cell phone
oh wow no wonder because I'm trying to
do it without her realizing that it's
being recorded that you can't do it so I
can get some natural I've gotten her pre
permission to go I see you don't want to
you don't want to she said I can do it
oh and I don't have to let her know she
gave me a pre oh so that she won't be
inhibited or faked yeah I wanted to get
like catch something that's not John
well where do you put the phone on the
other side of the room shut up Shirley
no I'm saying I record my I record my
sets on stage on my phone it works out
fine yeah I don't understand why you
can't record because you haven't PA
system there idiot that's how I'm not
recording with a speaker system like you
do at a comedy show your analogies dumb
we have to be able I agree what is it
dick JD the air conditioner more than
anything and 31 minutes long so Brent
gave you the tape and all you hear is
air conditioning
where do you live in Miami what do you
have the recorder near the
air-conditioner no it's near the bed but
the air-conditioner I think is on the
side of the bed cuz can you hear
anything on this tape submit some stuff
but it's all hard to hear for the most
part
who's louder Brent or is why I don't
make much noise I mean that's a guy you
really shouldn't what some of your dirty
talk like I do I just said that I'm
silent are you paying not really
interested he doesn't use I don't use
the guys should be quiet so I don't
usually listen I'm just trying to figure
out how to make them less creepy do that
for yourself buddy I'm fine with your
plaid shirt you want me to record as
anyone's whole things about one shuli in
the bedroom I want nothing to do I'll
stand there alright here's one here's a
preview Robin of Brent and Caitlin sorry
yeah I think it's the air conditioner
that it is it's really loud
all right I heard some moaning JD says
at one point in this paper Kaitlyn gets
up because you're taking so long to come
that she goes to the bathroom dirty yeah
yeah dude wait what's going on with you
hate that dude yeah dude I take a while
to finish how long is a while I can take
I can take 20 minutes yeah sometimes it
takes a while
Caitlin at one point gets up makes a
sandwich goes the bathroom and then
comes back to the bed to finish taxes
your sex tape number two phrases after
the break I don't know if it's before JD
before or after the break all right Wow
way to go Brent ran she loves it oh yeah
for you oh yes she's a wild one now are
you guys just sitting on the bed moving
it and faking this whole day playing
basketball check it or eat bail at was
boy Robin that was the real sound of
love I mean when a woman sounds like
that it means she's in ecstasy right
yeah don't you think it's weird we
didn't hear hardly anything and then
that part of the tape the air
conditionings turned down somehow okay
so you're accusing Brent oh I'm just
saying that part came in really clear
SJD of the tape was doctored if I gave
my raw tape JD was the tape doctor he's
an expert but who knows that's what our
expert now ended on I don't know she was
just making stuff up like he always does
just to be a dick just asking questions
no you're not you're just being a dick
all right anyway Thank You Brent for
that that was unbelievable